drug enforcement agents in the capital
of Lusaka show journalists the aircraft
that are causing so much speculation and
controversy in Zambia there was a story
that they had disappeared so I thought
maybe you could come through and see
them and convey the message to the
people example that nothing has gone
missing they are here we are going to
appear I take this medical Court very
very soon
the aircrafts along with guns bullets
cash and fake gold were seized by police
on August the 13th several arrests were
made including five Egyptian Nationals
that had been denied bail and charged
with corruption smuggling and Espionage
for entering a restricted Zone at the
airport
Egyptian authorities say the aircraft
are privately owned and were only in
transit when they landed in Cairo the
fact that it's a it's a private jet uh
uh make it related to the state one way
or another and the speculations was all
about the relation of Egypt as a state
with a private jet so
um a lot of news about Egyptian
authorities following up with a Zambian
authorities and following up on the
status of Egyptians there the accused
face up to 30 years in jail is convicted
when they stand trial zambians hope that
when it finally starts many of the
questions raised in this unusual police
investigation will be answered Al
Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera